[Music]
a houston man robbed
and kidnapped his own roommate at
gunpoint
after being asked to move out he was
asking for it
what was his end goal here you ever been
in a situation where you lived with
someone and they weren't paying rent and
you had to be like hey man i think you
gotta even pay rent or leave that's kind
of where they ended up and the dude in
response to that at gunpoint
made him uh give him money out of his
credit card so then he paid him out wait
where was he he robbed him and then he
goes all right
i thought he was gonna do that but no
instead he just he put him in the trunk
of his own car
drove his car around and then abandoned
the car on the road oh my god wait who
the guy that didn't pay rent robbed them
that'd be funny if the owner robbed him
once he was asking you gotta move out
and i'm robbing you you know what's
crazy about that though i grew up with a
dude
i don't know the details but he's doing
like
50 years or 60 years in a prison in
louisiana
apparently
he
him and his roommate fell out something
happened
and he killed the roommate and i don't
know if he initially i think he tried i
think he tried to put him on fire but it
didn't work so he rolled them up in one
of those big rugs
carried him outside
took him in the car threw him over a
bridge into a uh like a lake and the
body floated up
but the neighbor caught it all in the
ring
hey we're gonna get you dude dude he's
doing he's doing like life right now he
and the only reason like
my partner told me i'm like dude i said
because i said so-and-so hit me up on
facebook he's like what i'm like yes i
guess he somebody got a hold of a phone
he's like hey man i've seen you on vice
man how are you doing man paul this is
so-and-so i'm like damn dude where you
at he's like man i'm in hell right now
and then i asked the homie i'm like damn
what is he in there for he told me the
story i'm like
god dude how you you can't come back
from that yeah
dude they caught him he rolled him up
and he was dead he rolled the body up
with a thing and carried it outside they
got it all on video and then the body do
it over the river and then it floated
back up
and then when the trial means
dude it was it was his roommate it was a
boy they're out there selling drugs
again they're hustling so they got into
a fight or whatever yeah i don't i guess
something happened but he killed he he
killed the dude now that's the same
thing this guy said he said they've had
no uh beef or anything like they don't
they don't even really hang and then out
of nowhere once he was like yo i think
you got to move out because the dude
owns the house and he's like you gotta
move out of my house that's when he just
pulled this and it's on camera oh [ __ ]
it's on camera
let me tilt it a little bit more yeah
see you know what that that's he's got
to be on like some pills or some drugs
you know what i mean yeah
yeah very rational they just and you
don't
that's a nice house he's got the gun on
him huh yeah he's holding the gun around
bro what's the issue
what's the issue
that's the type of move clear the table
there's like one little
shaker
i mean
get on the table right here bro what the
hell so this guy this guy knew he had
rings in the house too and he was just
like yeah i'm just gonna do this here
not the smartest yeah an idiot he's a
roommate he's not we're in the age of
videos though man yeah
technology bro it's just gonna get
caught right yeah he doesn't seem like a
different thing
ring anything i mean surveillance tv tvs
it's all over the place try so hard to
get away with anything these days i got
all of that man tesla cars and [ __ ] you
know but it makes it so it makes it feel
pretty comfortable though when you have
that and your neighbors watching well
thank goodness for that and probably you
know need to go get a pit bull
up in there
like hey buddy get him you know me it's
like dude it's like at what point do
people like rationalizing like you said
it's your house man get the hell out i'm
done you know you're not you gotta go i
just wanna know what this guy's game
plan was like okay you're gonna rob him
you're gonna kidnap him and then what
like you're just gonna his game plan
literally so he that's the moment there
where he's got the gun on yeah right and
then he makes him do like a like a venmo
transfer like a bank
of like five g's or something so that's
great that's that's that's grand theft
five thousand months grand theft another
chart yeah wow
yeah and you have it in in writing too
yeah you got robbery kidnapping because
you're moving from one point to another
point
and you can see the amount so it's
probably easier to get it recovered if
you're the victim right because you
could you could tell your bank or
whatever yeah well yeah that's the
number
it's not like it's cash and it's like
undeterminable i hope he gets a little
bit of that rent money back too that he
hasn't been paying
you think you think this guy's got
anything left to give him probably went
to joe and called him hey can you just
click call from
hey hey you know we've had our
differences
come on dude i didn't mean it do you
think that's pilt like behavior yeah
yeah oh yeah i knew a dude on pill then
he and you know at one point he called
me like oh man there's people there
tripping man
i'm telling you there
he was like and he was on one and that's
when yeah he he got those pain with
pills man the drugs now these kids
they'd be having awesome [ __ ] man and
then they wake up like what i do
you know it's that roseanne one the
sleepy one remember that
she
like half hallucinating and [ __ ] ambient
was getting people to [ __ ] sleepwalk
and do weird [ __ ] but then ambien was
like nah that wasn't us
the bikes and then people are doing them
[ __ ] smoking oxies yeah yeah spicy
smoking on spice and bath fault damn
asshole's making all those zombies in
florida no no that sounds terrifying man
yeah that'll really make you hit the
salt shaker way off the table
i i lived with the roommate
uh that i didn't like so when i was in
mls school which is like your job school
in the military
um you have inspections like weekly
inspections
on your uh
well it's not squad bay but it's like uh
it's like it's like a room and then you
have like three or four other door mates
pretty much and then i like to work out
and so in the military you have very
uh when you're in school you have very
limited free time you know because you
have to you go to school and you gotta
do this and you have like company pt and
you have just so many [ __ ] things so
the only time that you really have is
like after dinner you have two hours
before you have to do the next thing so
for me that's valuable because i want to
go work out and then but on i think like
mondays or fridays where we have
inspections you have to clean it it has
to pass like a white glove inspection
like they put a white glove on they
touch everything
and then so for me like every monday i
just knew i'm gonna go in and clean up
like we already divvied everything up
but you're i'm doing the blinds or you
do the sheets or you do the bat or
whatever right so i did all my [ __ ] i'm
like all right guys i'm [ __ ] done uh
these two guys look like they're on
track i go to my other uh my other
roommate his name is perez and then he
was just sitting like in his like foot
locker thing
and he was sitting there like this i'm
like hey praise all you gotta do is this
i did like 75 because i want to rush out
i always do more so i did like 75
percent of [ __ ] on bounce uh all you got
to do is just do this and then he just
wouldn't even like talk to me and i was
like yo hello i'm talking to you and he
goes uh and he's like no i don't want to
i'm like what he goes and then he
started and i was like come on just
gotta do this and he was like nah [ __ ]
you damn whoa
whoa this is just like oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] and then you know when you
sometimes you hear those things it makes
you like cuckoo so i just started
bombing on that [ __ ]
dude this guy is crazy
get off first i just started bombing him
because it was just like
when people are down a reason i'm always
down to reason you know is it like oh
your hands are hurt who's having a
tantrum with you what is it like you
[ __ ] you if you've got a sweater you
can't wipe [ __ ]
take care of it this time like whatever
it is
or like i don't know i'll reason with
someone i wasn't expecting you to say i
started boxing
like in the military there's like less
than
[ __ ] at that time probably less than
like one percent asians right the next
day you got a rap huh the next day we
showed up in class
everyone looks at perez and he had
[ __ ] lumps all over his face
and then i'm just like he was still like
this
i'm just sitting in class like this and
you just see all the people
there's [ __ ] crazy
i'm just like i'm not crazy
[Laughter]
no never
every monday he knew exactly what to do
yeah there you go man sometimes
sometimes you can beat the crazy out of
somebody
you beat that ass you know what i mean
i would be like after a month later like
come on man why were you so mean to me
i'd be like why why did you say [ __ ] you
you're having a bad day on graduation
day i did go and like shake it i just
feel that i don't like bad feelings um
so i did go and shake his hand
he was like
why were you like that man and he was
just like i don't know
he's still giving you attitude
maybe he was one of those dudes that
like joined the military and halfway
through he was like this isn't what i
wanted so he was just like i'm not gonna
do [ __ ] and they're just taking it on
right now just having a moment yeah or i
don't know i don't know what it is but
it was just i was just now that was a
good lesson for him though because like
he said there's a consequence there
there's dad at that moment
[Laughter]
i was like i don't know i don't even
know if you use words i'll always use
words you can't get in trouble for what
you did yeah he said [ __ ] you he used
his word
yeah you're supposed to say [ __ ] you
back well he caught me with my pants
down
oh that's what this is about
i didn't know what to say i [ __ ]
malfunctioned
oh no uh he didn't report me which was
kind of cool oh
he could have what would have happened
oh man uh so the military version of
like getting in trouble be like njp so
it could be they they hold me there for
way longer or i don't graduate or i get
demoted and when you get demoted your
pay gets taken away like a lot of [ __ ]
could happen so they don't make him
explain why he's already but he could
but it could have backfired him too
could by telling they're like oh and
dude you didn't do this and why did he
do that yeah so because like the og's
was like oh okay you know what i mean
because they can't have a dude saying
[ __ ] you when they're on in combat
yeah you know i mean there's a different
mentality yeah when you're giving an
order you know
when i lived on military base nobody
took care nobody snitched on anybody you
get beat up and come home and it's like
you know it's just military death you
know like dude anybody telling over here
yeah go ahead and your business yeah
different mentality yeah he'll be in
bigger trouble for telling yeah you know
he would have gotten joke but like the
fact that everybody looked at him like
oh so you had it coming yeah yeah he
just didn't even want to have my side
yeah that's cool yeah yeah so from that
day on snitching was known as perezing
but he didn't snitch
[Music]
you